these cookies are a problem if they put
these cookies in hotels they wouldn't be
able to kick them out be like girl
let's check out time hey tasty fam my
name is keanu i'm the founder and editor
of jaconi and today i'll try to upgrade
the famous doubletree hotel chocolate
chip cookie for those who haven't heard
the hilton has recently released their
cookie recipe now there's some mixed
reviews about it some really really good
and others not so much it's all okay
there's always room for improvement and
that's what we're focusing on today self
improvement but like
for a cookie
so i have the recipe written down i'm
gonna make it exactly as it's written
down give it a try and then see where
there's room for improvement so first
things first my butter is at room
temperature so it can whip
nice and fluffy white sugar light brown
sugar almost equal parts there's a
tablespoon more of white sugar a lot of
cookies start off this way cream
together your butter and sugar until
light and fluffy
if you don't have a stand mixer you can
always use an electric hand mixer and if
you don't have one of those you got the
mixers you were born with
all right this looks right to me i have
two large eggs at room temperature it's
kind of rule of thumb when you're baking
your
ingredients that could be in the fridge
are at room temperature some vanilla
extract
and it also asks for
lemon
to activate our leavener it's not really
gonna
flavor the cookie to taste like lemon
like four drops we're gonna beat it some
more first on low for 30 seconds go for
another two minutes
like what am i doing with this lemon i
don't like wasting things so
um
all right this is looking mighty fluffy
and now on to the dry ingredients two
and a quarter cups all-purpose flour and
then
a little bit of oats like a smidge half
a cup of that's going in there some
baking soda now this is
why they wanted the lemon but it's a
it's a cookie it doesn't need it's not
cake but you know in it goes
some salt a teaspoon of that and the
last ingredient
cinnamon so i'm going to mix this on low
speed for
45 seconds
being careful not to over mix which i
can feel like 45 seconds is a lot it's
been like 20 seconds and it's already
incorporated so i want to stop mixing
can i stop mixing dear god i cannot i
cannot let this go for 45 seconds these
cookies will be frisbees so this recipe
calls for a very particular brand of
chocolate chips so that's what we are
going to use
two and two thirds cup of chocolate
there's only so great the cookie can
taste if your chocolate is
meh one and three quarter cup of walnuts
this is
more walnuts than i've ever seen going
into any single baked good just with a
spatula i'm going to fold this together
i've never made a chocolate chip cookie
dough this pale before baking sheets
lined with some parchment paper normally
i chill my cookie dough
before baking it but this doesn't ask
for that scoop and drop so it's about
three tablespoons of
cookie dough
cookie this dough the recipe says you
can freeze it if you want to and these
guys these are going into the oven 300
degrees between 20 and 23 minutes so
it's kind of a lower temperature bake
them until they're golden on the edges
and nice and
tender in the middle
cookies are out the oven and they are
they are the same color as my parchment
paper they're not lookers i wouldn't
swipe right it's a lot of walnuts
looking back at me
these are worse than i thought they were
gonna be i really thought they're gonna
be like fine
these cookies fell
flat in many ways but i have some ideas
of how we can build on the foundation of
this recipe and make them
the best version of themselves they can
be it is a cookie makeover y'all
time to make the cookie upgrade first
thing is
the butter i'm going to brown the butter
it's going to help bring out this
nuttiness
that the other cookie wasn't having pop
this on some heat medium medium low the
goal is not to burn the butter i want a
nice
light caramel it's like the butter is
seasoning itself when it browns keeping
a very
close eye on it because once
it hits that line from brown to burnt
you can't come back in the meantime i
have a baking sheet lined with parchment
toast the walnuts in the original recipe
they were giving me flavor just like my
butter i'm gonna brown them i'm using
significantly less walnuts because i
don't want them to overpower the main
star no oil no anything they go in dry
there's a natural oil in the nut 350
degrees five to seven minutes also
keeping a close eye
watch after your butter and your nuts
like they are your children butter is
beautiful golden brown like you will
smell it check these walnuts these are
awake that's all you're doing in the
oven you're just waking them up i have
my butter
beautiful and brown it's going to
carefully pour
now you want to be careful not to get
all those burnt milk solids in there
brown and white sugar but i am switching
the quantities brown sugar makes cookies
soft so i'm doing two to one ratio of
brown sugar to white sugar so i have one
cup of brown sugar and a half a cup of
white sugar all you need is a whisk the
butter is already melted so this should
come together really easy every stir is
just like fragrance fragrance fragrance
ah
if you see any brown sugar lumps just
break them up with the head of your
whisk you want your food to talk back to
you this is telling me it's gonna be
delicious so using a sexy phone voice
like
hey girl
how you doing
i'd like to introduce myself my name is
brown
brown butter brown butter is magic y'all
i'm adding in eggs same as last time two
large eggs room temperature look at this
beautiful
beautiful brown
and you know this stuff is done
once your batter slowly
flows into each other i really want to
accentuate the flavors we're working
with just one teaspoon of almond and
this will really help bring out a true
nutty flavor
same amount of all-purpose flour as
before the same amount of oats
and
baking soda
give it a good gentle fold using a
spatula
for the salt i'm going to be using some
sea salt sea salt is a beautiful
complement to chocolate it's okay if
there's little speckles of white flour
chocolate chip cookies keyword chocolate
the best chocolate you can find is the
chocolate you want to use
i'm using
this
bar
halfway between semi-sweet and dark
chocolate and cut this chocolate into
chunks
little bits
and that way it's like a complexity of
chocolate you'll have a chocolate shard
a chocolate sliver slide them out in i'm
gonna put in these walnuts
fold them in
until it's nice and evenly distributed
so i'm going to cover and chill this
dough
for two hours or overnight
it's chilled it is firm i'm so excited
to finally bake these so each cookie
dough ball is around two ounces each
working quickly you're just gonna
compress it together
in that curvy part of your hand
and just shape it into a quick little
ball you don't want to play with this
too long because your chocolate will
melt i can smell all the beautiful
flavors in there so just a tiny sprinkle
of sea salt on top of these cookies
is going to help bring out that
chocolate flavor i'm going gonna bake
them 350 so harder than last time
for 12 to 15 minutes
wow
look at them
first noticeable difference is shape and
size complex in texture there's so many
things going on it's just like a happy
party i do have to wait for them to cool
but not an hour maybe just 15 minutes so
they can
relax
this is the best part about a warm
cookie is just breaking it oh
man
[Music]
these are wicked these cookies are a
problem if they put these cookies in
hotels they wouldn't be able to kick
them out be like girl
check out time what i love about this
upgrade is that there's so many things
you can do to this recipe to make it
better with the exact same ingredients
upgrading doesn't always have to mean
spending more money
i hope you give my upgraded doubletree
chocolate chip cookies a try and if you
do
show me the goods i want to see the
cookies you're making and until next
time
a bid you do
you